you were convicted 1964 for conspiracy
against the state and in your when you
pleaded you said that I am willing to
die for this cause this is very tough
thing to say yes I had to say that not
from a spirit of bravado but because I
really felt that they were going to hang
on it is the desire of every freedom
fighter to disappear under a cloud of
glory
- dr. faith it is the task of a freedom
fighter when you see that at the end of
your days has come to live a tradition
of braver determination to face even
death for your own principle and I
thought about it was not because I and
society in which all persons live look
at income and with equal opportunities
it is an ideal for which I hope to live
and to see
realized but my lord if it needs be it
is an ideal for which I am prepared to
die anybody would changes his principles
depending on whom he is dealing that is
not a man who can lead a nation I have
refused to be drawn into the differences
that existed between various communities
inside the USA why are you so keen that
I should involve myself in the internal
affairs of Cuba and Libya I expect you
to be consistent you just watched two
amazing clips from Nelson Mandela take
the next three minutes and sit quietly
to think about how you can apply them to
your business and your life believe
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]